[Music]  keeping up with the kardashians  finally addresses that Scott Disick  dating Sophia Ricci by having a momager  Kris Jenner grill him about it  [Music]  [Music]  wait I really don't use duty yeah  Chris's initial shock starts to wear off  when she realizes that she was only 17  when she started dating a 29 year old  Robert Kardashian oh well after watch  and see if the rest of the family weighs  in on the relationship too  back in October a source told et Scott's  ex Kourtney Kardashian does not care who  he dates though courts sister Kendall  Jenner has seemingly vanished shading  Sophia on social media over the last few  weeks a lot of madness you know still  Scott and Sophia have been going strong  for more than five months now oh yeah  Botox caught them out on a date night  this week in Malibu  donning matching camo outfits  [Music]